All right, guys, so in this very first example, we're going to talk about monthly bias.
And if you see these arrows here, that is basically fractals.
It tells you the correct highs and lows.
So you don't, you know, like take a wrong low for a market structure shift or a long
higher low for external degree.
So you can just go to indicator shares, type in fractals, right?
And you want to use the fractals by Rachel T.
So these are my colors.
I use black and this green over here, it makes it clean, okay?
So now on the monthly timeframe, what I can see here is price has taken out a fixed external
liquidity, right?
Remember, every single high or low is an external liquidity.
And what do we have below this over here?
You are right.
We have the internal liquidity, which is the fair value gap.
Cool.
We have taken out the external liquidity here, what we want to do, remember for monthly
for bias, we want to drop from monthly to daily timeframe.
Now once we drop down to the daily timeframe, you can see right here this, if you didn't
have the fractals on, you would have considered this as your shift in the structure, which
is, you know, so anyways, this is our low here.
We want to see a bridge of this low.
And right here, you can see we have a market structure shift, right?
So now what do you see here?
We have taken out external.
So this is the fair value gap that we should look to target, okay?
I mean, when you are on the daily timeframe, of course, but we're talking about monthly.
So now when we have the market structure shift here, we can simply take our entry from
this fair value gap, okay?
Or this fair value gap, but remember our target is this level.
So you can simply just go short right here, put your stop right above this high and go
for one, just target this level, okay?
So now once you get the marketer shift, your monthly bias is here, okay?
So just you are, you're going to be like confident, you can be taking trades until
this level is hit, but of course on the daily and the one hour timeframe.
But for now, let's see how this plays out.
The simple bread and butter model, we have our entry here.
And that is basically for swing traders, okay?
So right here, you can see that beautiful price delivery, we took out the monthly extended
liquidity here, right?
And we went up and we then had a market structure shift right here.
And this is the fair value gap in the premium.
We take a trade here and we just drop down below.
Very simple.
But you could have taken trades with a high risk reward ratio on the one hour timeframe,
but I will get to that later, okay?
Just remember that once you get a market structure shift, your bias is set, okay?
When body closes, that's like you're, okay, we are bearish till this level is taken up.
So let me give you guys an example for the weekly bias now.